nous aurions pu vous parler de
l'incivilité de jeter ses mégots par
terre du risque d'être verbalisé 68
euros de la saleté et du dégoût provoqué
chez les patients non fumeurs au lieu de
ça parlons de bourges de la beauté de
ses rues du charme des pavés sous le
soleil et des personnes rares comme
valérie en terrasse klopp une gamme
regarder il est là je mets tout dans un
petit papier je jette après dans la
poubelle quand je pars sur les terrasses
les gens ils fument et boivent donc nous
notre rôle c'est de tenir le lieu propre
et de balayer malgré que c'est toujours
un peu embêtant et pour les mégots tombé
par inadvertance d'une main de fumeurs
dans la rue ils ont une fâcheuse
tendance à aller se loger entre deux
pavés à l'abri du ballet de cantonniers
et de la balayeuse automatique la ville
vient d'acheter glouton un aspirateur
tout électrique et silencieux il ne
faudrait pas réveiller le citoyen qui
sommeille même si certains furent donc
ya pas de dégagement de poussière
il n'y a pas de contact avec les déchets
n'ont pu par le par l'utilisateur en
carburant par exemple sur la balayeuse
électrique journaliers en fait ça fait à
peu près entre 50 60 euros pour
travailler et là avec une balayeuse
électrique c30 sur les parkings bas il y
en a qui jettent leur cendrier par terre
et puis après comme ils disent c'est les
gens de la ville
on va ramasser par faire mais même
devant devant nous quoi qui met dedans
qu'ils écrasent leurs cigarettes et me
donne des ailes
un filtre de cigarette mais 10 à 15 ans
à se dégrader et chaque mégots contient
des métaux lourds et des pôles ont du
cadmium du plomb et de la nicotine les
rats adore la nicotine les mégots de
bourges qui ne sont pas ramassés tombe
dans les bouches d'égout
direction la rivière la loire puis la
mer alors pensez aux poissons et adopter
le cendrier